michel larive député la france insoumise
de la 2e circonscription de l'ariège
monfort michel larive merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france prolongation donc
adopté en première lecture mais les
débats ont été plutôt animée à
l'assemblée nationale hier ils ont été
animées moi j'aimerais revenir un petit
peu sur ce qui s'installe on se refuse
son intégrité et maintenant contestait
pourquoi parce que le matin et le soir
lorsque les gens vont au travail
il foule sont de plus en plus dense
puisque les journées sont plus courtes
avec le couvre feu
il ya donc des vecteurs de diffusion de
l'épidémie qui sont plus grands
d'ailleurs en allemagne il ya une
décision du tribunal administratif qui
signifie que la mesure que le feu
n'était pas raide n'amenez pas une
réduction significative de l'incidence
de l'infection peut se poser déjà ceci
est surtout l'acceptation des mesures et
la manière dont le gouvernement s'y
prend et vous avez raisons diverses
cette proposition de prolongation de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
jusqu'au mas de jusqu'au 16 février 2021
ces trois mois de plus ce sont des lieux
d'exception qui est à petit cette hand
et qui vise d'ailleurs à être sûrement
parce que le parlement se saisisse d'une
proposition de loi sur en janvier 2021 à
être inscrit dans le droit commun il ya
un problème là un problème de loin qui
deviennent des taquets devient de plus
en plus des bergues liberticide on va là
légiférer maintenant dans l'article 4 de
cette loi un parent ordonnant cette
année on n'aura plus besoin de passer
devant le parlement pour pouvoir
certes ce qu'on a envie de faire
carrément en france qu'elle se soit
liberticide ou pas et ça ça peut
véritablement un problème cet état
d'exception qui est en train de se
prolonger
la problématique est véritablement là
alors les français peuvent accepter le
fait de contraintes fortes
à partir du moment où ils ont des
résultats est depuis six mois depuis la
première vague nous avions nous aussi
matin de déconfinement annoncé qu'il
fallait faire quelque chose qu'il
fallait planifié en cas de deuxième
vague qui s'annonçait déjà hélas ça naît
ça ne s'est pas passé depuis six mois
monsieur déconfinement monsieur castel
cia devenu premier ministre nommé devant
un fait accompli on voit effectivement
le gouvernement navigue à vue et il ya
une problématique in fine et
d'acceptation de ces contraintes par la
population
comment va-t-elle réagir moi je pense qu
il faut accepter ce qu'il se passe
aujourd'hui mais il faut que le
gouvernement nous donne des perspectives
qu'il n'y a pas de perspective
et s'il n'y a qu'un décompte morbide
tous les soirs ça va poser un problème
j'en suis sûr temps alors il y à
davantage de cas de contamination ou là
vous l'avez expliqué il ya beaucoup de
gens qui prennent les transports en
commun notamment sans cesse décès
supplémentaires on n'est pas non plus
dans la ligne rouge qu'il y avait en
mars dernier vous parliez de
d'un régime d'exception les français ont
du mal à comprendre justement ces
mesures restrictives qui sont plutôt
punitive selon eux et on aura les
résultats évidemment que la semaine
prochaine ont dit le gouvernement
qu'attendez vous de la part de ce
gouvernement à partir de la semaine
prochaine si par exemple on démontre que
ce couvre-feu n'a pas d'impact sur la
hausse des contaminations
que voulez-vous qu'il advienne si jamais
le couvre-feu n'a pas un impact sur la
hausse des comptes et une
décontamination
c'est l'étape d'après c'est le
confinement le confinement peut être
sectorielles ou deux pays un président
de la république n'a exclu aucune
alternative
donc je pense que ce couvre-feu était il
bien bien utile j'allais en métropole
peut être en jaune de vale à 21 heures à
21 heures en général
si par exemple il ya déjà moins de monde
dehors surtout à cette époque le t2 un
peu plus mais en zone urbaine
on va avoir une conséquence économique
dramatique elle en général aussi bien
sur l conséquences et qu'on est
dramatique et tu vas et encore plus avec
un confinement
alors on répond pu éviter ceci voilà
c'était l'alternative
si jamais ça ne fonctionne pas
l'alternative au couvre-feu
c'est le confinement évidemment les
français ce qu'on sait pas trop flexible
finalement des français qui contourne ce
couvre-feu les jeunes notamment en
organisant évidemment des soirées à
domicile et parfois même jusqu'à 6
heures du matin donc il ya des effets
pervers aussi a ses règles punitive
oui alors là écoutez moi je suis pas moi
je sais pas si je n'ai pas envie de le
stigmatiser une partie de la population
contre une autre
j'attends ce que les jeunes ont assez
pris donc je crois que l'ordre le fait
d'être des vecteurs de conduite
contamination ou autre je crois qu'on
est tous là dans le même bateau qu'il
faut agir en responsabilité certes mais
il faut que l'on puisse avoir conscience
que ceux qui nous gouvernent à 6 aussi
en responsabilité moi ce que je vois
c'est que les français sont plutôt
disciplinés sur le port du masque est
sûre
les gestes barrières sur les
distanciation physiques dont amenant de
la vie je crois qu'il faut que le père
ne lui prenne ses responsabilités les
gens les prennent les français les
prennent plutôt bien même je dirais
est-ce qu'on se trompe pas de je ne
stigmatise absolument pas les jeunes
évidemment mais est ce que la question
est est-ce qu'on se trompe pas de cible
finalement ce sont les plus fragiles
qu'il faudrait confiné si on est logique
avec cette propagation du virus et
éviter notamment les engorgements dans
les hôpitaux
peut-être peut-être mais je ne suis pas
ni médecin ni l'épidémiologiste donc je
n'ai peut-être pas la meilleure
stratégie
mais en tout cas l'idée c'était de
hausse au soir et au matin du
confinement pouvoir planifier ce qui
pourrait se passer lors d'une deuxième
vague ça n'a pas été fait vous avez
peut-être raison c'était peut-être une
des solutions peut-être qu'il y en avait
d'autres mais en tout cas rien n'a été
planifiée et ça c'est plutôt très
embêtant par contre ce qui se passe
c'est tout
on va voir là un contre sens d'avoir un
état d'urgence on va avoir un état
d'exception qui va se prolonger
et ça c'est embêtant comment la
population française d'accepter ceci
s'est pas seulement la population
française je regardais en europe en
europe ça commence à bouger et notamment
en allemagne
je trouve que les français eux sont
beaucoup plus dans l'acceptation que ce
qui peut se passer en allemagne
les tensions actuelles que nous
décrivent les soignants dans les
hôpitaux aurait-elle pu être évitée
selon vous oui madame
oui madame si on avait fait le
nécessaire les médias comme des choses
qui sont l'envoyeur on parle par exemple
de le 2e de cette proposition de
prorogation de l'état d'urgence et en
même temps il vient le le projet de loi
de finances de la sécurité sociale
et là c'est près d'un milliard d'euros
qui vont être rabotées pour les hôpitaux
environ cent mille neuf cent millions
d'euros or neuf seul 2021 il ya eu plus
de sept mille lits depuis 2010 9 qui ont
été supprimés dont vous voyez ce que je
veux dire on ne peut pas
si on doit se donner le gouvernement
doit donner les moyens aux services de
santé français de pouvoir fonctionner
correctement et de pouvoir répondre
lorsqu'il ya des problèmes de crises
sanitaires extrêmement importants comme
celui que nous vivons en ce moment on ne
peut pas à la fois vouloir essayer de
résoudre une crise et ne pas donner les
moyens dessus de résoudre cette crise et
à ça et puis il ya aussi des équipements
de protection
ils chutent intense et des masques à qui
manque est maintenant ce sont les gants
nous militons pour la gratuité des
masques voilà pas surveillé quant à
masquer ce n'est pas gratuit et il coûte
peut-être une famille 200 euros pas
moins qu'est ce qui se passe on va
garder le même mince et c'est à dire
qu'en fait la protection elle n'est plus
efficace
donc à partir de ce moment là il ya un
dysfonctionnement des mesures qui sont
mises en place entre le l'état de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire et l'abandon de
l'hôpital et puis le monde de moyens et
le manque aussi de personnel lors du
confinement du personnel étaient à
disposition parce qu'ils étaient
confinés là aujourd'hui ils sont déjà en
poste sur d'autres interventions
donc ça pose un problème véritablement
énorme de fonctionnement des hôpitaux
ils sont très fatigués ils nous l'ont
dit merci beaucoup michel larive d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce soir sur arte
france